I've asked you this before and I
remember you told me I asked you once
what percentage of the world do you
think you could beat in the fight and
you said like ninety-nine ninety-nine
point nine something like that but how
is when I see the house society
extra-extra corona yeah how they reacted
Corona about ninety nine point but Bryan
Callen oh damn she's a baddie
well she's percentage of the what
percentage of the world do you think
they use what percentage of the world do
you think you could beat me
ninety-nine you think you're up at nine
let me let me put it this way keep I'll
keep a lot of people busy and with a few
with thirty percent give you a little
credit to 30 percent already athletic
thirty percent of the world on already
athletic and I was rated percent a world
well I still train are you give waiter
what percentage of women are you saying
could beat them up because you got a
pursued fifty percent of the world is
women right is that right no I most
almost all women it is this ninety
percent women man I try I'm no no no I'm
not saying you can beat up I'm saying
fifty percent of the world are women but
I mean yeah so you could go 99 percent
of women may I don't know a lot of them
yeah look at the bottom line is I'm I'll
keep I'll surprise you and I don't like
his [ __ ] that take it back 35 percent
well no I I want and no one in the UFC
no females in the FC uh Brad I got you
eight about 68% yeah though and maybe
more than that I'll give you know I'll
give you 60% the way societies active
but I'm pretty athletic
you've seen me [ __ ] roll and about
possible you're 52 53 53 pretty good man
I mean not this but pretty good I'm
pissed off you know he's probably right
but that's still a lot of people I don't
hear that's I still spar spar two days
ago I didn't spar I moved around with a
pro and I got I hit him and he kind of
tapped me around I just watched him yeah
paid him on you know it's fine if you
spar with somebody can't say you spray I
can't say I sparred with if you have you
pay a pro to spar with you yeah you know
they want to keep your money of course
they want you to keep also also that by
the way they're not gonna hit me because
they would kick
don't say you've sparred with pros when
you're an actor you can't say that it's
just different
right these oh so what I do is I get hit
a little note you did for round you
moved around got a sweat on that's right
but no it's not boxing you moved around
the last time I walked in it's a little
not exact he's hitting me back he's not
hitting you back tap me up a little bit
not real the last time I sparred I
sparred with a was a sparring class
today
he's annoying though yeah well your home
your mouth thing set me on a bad my dad
told me drink milk we undo biggest the
biggest argument yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]